normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Elon
musk's X follows through with
thermonuclear lawsuit against Media
Matters messaging platform XS on Monday
sued Media Matters Watchdog group uh
sued Media Watch Dog group Media Matters
alleging the organization defamed the
platform after it published a report
that said ads for Major Brands had
appeared next to uh next two posts
touting Nazism now here's where it gets
U uh really fascinating I'll tell you
I'll break it down for you very simply
what Elon Musk is saying as well as
several employees publicly stating this
what Media Matters for America did to
understand what Media Matters is there
is a series of democrat and government
aligned groups that engage in lawfare
and cancel culture to destroy people who
believe in Liberty among one thing and
those who are conservative and so what
they're saying they're alleging what
Media Matters did and this is really
fascinating Media Matters created new
accounts or accessed accounts that had
been around for just 30 days to bypass
certain restrictions they then
intentionally followed a a handful of
Nazi accounts and a handful of
Advertiser accounts to to create a
timeline where their posts existed next
to each other that's pretty amazing
isn't it yeah so if you choose if I
choose to follow Phil and choose to
follow Danny and then I get a post from
Phil and a post from Danny I go oh why
why is this post from this offensive
comedian appearing next to my awesome
heav metal music it's it's like actually
going to be like because you chose for
it to because you wanted it this is a
free speech platform we we're allowing
the point is we're allowing you to do
that so we uh we have the document here
got it yeah so the document is up we
have it right here United States
district court for the Northern District
of Texas Fort Worth division EXC Corp
and NADA Corporation versus Media
Matters for America they say defendant
Media Matters for America is a
self-proclaimed Media Watch Dog that
decided it would not let the truth get
in the way of a story it wanted to
publish about excort looking to portray
X's social networking platform as being
dominated by white nationalists and
anti-semitic conspiracy theories Media
Matters knowingly and maliciously
manufactured side-by-side images
depicting advertisers post and excorp
social media platforms besides Neo-Nazi
and white nationalist Fringe content and
then portrayed these manufactured images
as if they were
typical as if they were what typical ex
users experienced in the platform Media
Matters designed both these images and
its resulting media strategy to drive
advertisers from the platform and
Destroy excorp and as of right now this
is a big deal we got Apple IBM Lionsgate
Disney Comcast nbcu Paramount Warner
Brothers Discovery and other firms have
paused their marketing this is a massive
hit to X's Revenue based on lies they
going to say plaintiff XC Corp operates
the social media platform with over 500
million active monthly users facilitates
free expression open discourse etc etc
we get it we get it so now we're hearing
I think it's the AG out of Missouri is
investigating fraud because it's both
civil and criminal fraud at at this
point and I got to be honest I think any
reasonable person who looks at what
Media Matters does will conclude it is
it is a it is a it's fraud yeah when
when an organization lies intentionally
and then uses those lies to engage in
torous
interference now you've got you're going
Beyond just a civil civil case it's
criminal yeah I mean Apple alone is I
think they said Apple alone spends a
$100 million a year I don't know what
the grand total of all these companies
is but that's some serious
damage Barry Media Matters I mean that I
don't know what kind of uh you know
margin they make but or what kind of
well they're like a nonprofit yeah it's
a nonprofit it's it's I think El might
just own them after this he's going to
do the same thing nonprofit you don't
own them it's just they're going to
there's not much you can do evil people
do evil things and even if they're on
the hook to Elon Musk for substantial
sums of money they keep doing what
they're doing I mean evil exists man
well I mean if there is Criminal
prosecution that might actually change
Behavior because then that'll turn into
uh you know there could be prosecution
for for criminal put them in jail or
something sure I don't think there would
be for there's attempts there's the Tim
mentioned the uh Missouri case but also
the uh owner of Rumble was just tweeting
I don't know where it went to uh was
just tweeting that trying to get the
attention of Jim Jordan and and Congress
so I don't know yeah I don't know what
protections a nonprofit has
like this I think the flood gates are
are busting open I don't think that many
people really buy this stuff anymore
because it's it's not that yeah the uh
uh I agree with you but if if uh the
Republicans look into the taking down of
parlor now it's big yeah yeah we're
talking about the government colluding
with private organizations to shut down
businesses to censor speech this goes
well beyond just someone got banned on
Twitter yeah I mean parlor was clearly
an effort to to shut down any possible
uh you know counternarrative to what was
being put on Twitter when before you
know after after January 6th it was
clear I mean Amazon shut their servers
down there was all kinds of push from
the government to to shut them down I
don't know I don't remember the details
but yeah they had their servers like
pulled basically you know I I don't
think that that's there's not a whole
lot of question as to whether or not
that happened I don't hear people saying
No this didn't happen or whatever um you
know so it was pretty clearly I'm
curious how long these these companies
are going to cuz I'm sure Twitter has
provided them with a report they did
right saying like hey here's our like
backend data just saying like hey this
is totally misrepresented they break it
down I mean this is actually quite
hilarious what what they're arguing in
the lawsuit is that Media Matters
exclusively followed a small subset of
users consisting entirely of accounts in
one of two categories those known to
produce extreme Fringe content and
accounts owned by X's bigname
advertisers the end result was a feed
Precision designed by medium matters for
a single purpose to produce side by side
ad content placements that it could
screenshot in an effort to alienate
advertisers yo they followed crazy guy
followed apple and then went oh no the
posts are appearing next to each other
but that's quite literally you choosing
yeah that's I I mean the question is how
long all these companies kind of keep up
with because they've done this before
didn't they recently do this exact same
thing where all these advertisers paused
I don't remember what the last but like
someone did similar they go hey you know
what's going on and all these or like
something Elon tweeted and then
everybody paused and then they come back
and they're like I I'm going there's
serious damages like a week of no ads
yes that I mean that's significant Dam
huge money I got elon's play for you I
said this during the YouTube ad
apocalypse and I'm going to say it now
and I hope Elon here's it here's what
you do buddy let's play a game IBM Apple
insert company nbcu they want to go to
war with you over something that is
obviously and knowingly false I wanted
to I want everyone to understand this
you think Apple doesn't know this is
fake yeah there's no way their marketing
people are like oh heavens me I can't
believe this happening no they know
exactly what it is it's curated and it's
fake so here's what you do Elon
advertise against them and what I would
say is whatever amount of money you'd
spend in marketing that you pull off the
table we will cost you tfold in negative
press yeah good luck the way I the way I
viewed it with you with YouTube was when
you know big company X announces they're
pulling up the platform I'd immediately
offer a premium deal to their main
competition Apple wants to jump off the
platform i' go to Microsoft and say
we'll give you the double double the
access for half the cost Microsoft then
goes oh oh boy now we're getting a
premium deal and here's what you do make
the ads and Sal Apple now Apple's got to
contend with massive multi-million
dollar marketing against them because
they chose to play with the live yeah th
this is probably just like the most like
basic cya for them and they'll just you
know they they'll be back I imagine
they'll all be back in short order
what's cya cover your ass they just go
hey like someone said something and they
go we they play it the most safest
possible but you said a moment ago like
you know no one's really falling for it
anymore yeah I don't think they're
falling forward either and I don't think
they're concerned I think they're part
no I mean like the regular people cuz
the thing with Media Matters I don't
exactly know their thing but like like
the biggest competition to mainstream
media right now is X like if I turn on
CNN or Fox right now or MSNBC like I'm
just watching what I saw on Twitter
yesterday yeah YouTube YouTube and NX I
would say YouTube's like the ultimate
although YouTube's kind of mainstream
thing Twitter has the real citizen
journalism though where like you know
something happens and there's just a guy
like there who's just even even YouTube
is is a day late because everyone that's
talking about you know what's going on
if they're making videos yeah it takes
at least a few hours to produce it
unless you're doing like live stream
stuff and that stuff is done on X
nowadays people are if you want to look
for the most recent news it's going to
be on X always been that way right I'm
on the ground at Occupy Wall Street the
video is instantly up on Twitter Youtube
was like it doesn't really work that way
yeah it's it's just a slightly different
way that people injust that that content
there's production value like I mean
even even low low you know people that
Pride themselves on low production value
or you know looking like it's DIY and
stuff there's some production value
whether it be editing or stuff like that
so you can't get it up as fast as you
can on you a giant car like car crash or
something it's just someone whips out
their phone and they go this is you know
crazy and then that's that's where
you're going to see it first before
anywhere so and you know you're not
going to get banned off X for uploading
it whereas on YouTube it's like did you
vet this you better if you're going to
say this is real by posting it then you
better vet this even if even if you did
vet it even if it is real they'll just
they'll still just kick you off or
whatever demon it depends certain
certain things yeah but it's like it's
not it's not like The Proving Ground is
kind of X it's like the testing ground
for data fake stuff goes up real stuff
goes up and then we decide what's real
and then we put that on YouTube Here's
the wild here's the wild thing if Jack
dorsy Still owned X Twitter you would be
banned for criticizing Hamas not I I I
think it is a very very strong
likelihood that you know what was it
Facebook's rules said that you were
allowed to praise Nazis so long as they
were fighting in Russia yeah right so
it's like I'm pretty sure that uh I mean
the crazy thing right now is uh Michael
Rapaport if you saw on Instagram if you
go to follow him on Instagram right now
it gives you the warning that says this
account posts um like controversial
thing no not controversial it's like
fake and misleading oh is got as soon as
he said he'd vote for Trump they got him
isn't that crazy someone sent that to me
I go I couldn't believe it I had to see
for myself and it literally says if you
go follow Michael rap we pull that up
we'll pull that up in I have it I took a
screen shot of on my phone and uh cuz
I'm like rap aore you think that guy's
been orange man bad for but he just came
out and said he's he's considering
voting for trump it says this this are
you sure you want to follow Michael
Rapaport this account has repeatedly
posted false information that was
reviewed by independent fact Checkers or
went
against this is why they need to destroy
X Elon Musk shattered a large portion of
their narrative control that's what I'm
saying yeah so some argue a lot people
on the left argue that if uh if Jack
dorsy on the platform you would not be
able to criticize Israel I I I think
it's the other way around I mean I I got
kicked off Instagram recently on October
8th is when I started but I I think it
Donald Trump being the biggest issue for
them Michael Rapaport makes a video
where he's like big dick Donald Trump
I'm gonna vote for him I'm considering
it and then it's like and it's funny
because he kind of sounds like a
high-pitch version of trump and and now
they're putting a a flag on his account
crazy cuz he's like been the most just
like every allowable opinion orange man
all that stuff forever and then the
moment he veers off of the acceptable
kind of stuff Gone Gone let's carry this
on we got this tweet from Chris
pavlovski he says X is not alone I can
also confirm that Media Matters has
purposely misrepresented Rumble their
dishonesty warrants an immediate
investigation at the highest levels and
he says hint speaker Johnson and Jim
Jordan and I'll bring the receipts
here's my statement he says Media
Matters is threatened by rumble's
mission to protect a free and open
internet so the reaction is to deceive
the public and scare advertisers for
example on March 14th Media Matters
claimed that advertisements for Netflix
which were appearing on Rumble had been
placed on videos that violated our
content policies however according to
Google analytics the week before
publication of that Media Matters
article there had been zero page views
of that video this means that the Media
Matters activist who took the
screenshots was the first human being to
actually view the Netflix ad on the
video in question though their story
left the false impression that it was a
widespread problem the same is true for
most of the video videos set by Media
Matters all of which were removed from
Rumble as soon as we were made aware of
them it's clear that Media Matters
intends to mislead and deceive about
advertisements on Rumble in order to
hamper free speech and harm law iding
employers who only want to advertise
their product and services yo it's
torous interference you there's no
reason why you you can't just say you
know Chris and El they're trying to cost
you money and damage your business take
it to the the the monetary uh issue
right here prove damages let Media
Matters outright admit
that they're doing this and then show it
to a judge do we know who funds them uh
it's it well probably George Soros yeah
that would be no I think that's actually
easily confirmed that was a big article
that people were sharing but it's it's a
nonprofit that receives a bunch of
donations he says Media Matters doesn't
do anything for free so who is funding
this outrageous targeting activity who
is paying for them to Target free speech
and and why are they afraid ofe free
expression online speaker Johnson rep
Jordan it's time for Congress to ask
hard questions Elon Musk respond saying
they have a long track record of evil
Deeds an investigation is badly needed I
will tell you this right now I will
place a large sum of money I mean this
figuratively a gentleman's bet let's say
that sure that the US government is
working directly with Media Matters in
some way yeah yeah us us what's probably
happening is government actors and Media
Matters employees probably are in
regular communication to coordinate
their efforts and Target social media
platforms with allies who work for these
companies we know this is a fact that
the government did this now media
yet to be seen but the government did do
this with vag who had regular meetings
with them and gave them a back door and
Facebook gave the government a back door
the US government has gone Rogue in this
regard I mean we can say they've gone
Rogue in terms of War when was the last
time the US declared war they've gone
Rogue in basically every way you can
imagine it they don't they don't they
don't take care of the Border they
violate individuals rights by spying on
them we the I don't believe that the NSA
has stopped spying even though there's
there they're supposed to have stopped
collecting metadata I don't believe they
are and the reason I don't believe they
are is because if they want they let
Google and and all the the companies
these big tech companies they let them
collect the data and then they just
subpoena it so they don't their hands
are clean but if they want it you they
know that these big tech companies are
going to give it to them so they're
monitoring everything you do ring will
will monitor you with with cameras at
your house there's cameras all over
every major city the the number of
individual liberties that are
specifically
protected by the Constitution is equal
to the number of individual liberties
that the federal government violates on
a regular basis thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net